right Part C now the exact wedding is
hmm show that the derivative is zero at
now I you actually don't need me to tell
you what point does is driven in 20 I'm
gonna Fester there's a dream if right
there it this derivative equals zero at
negative 2 right so they say show that
that every 20 into two but then they
follow up and say explain why there is
the stationary point there so let's do
this one at a time right they do say
show they do cetera so you can't just
skip this over we're going to pop this
in right when X is a party when x equals
negative 2 dy m TX is just don't just
see zero I know you're like of course
it's zero but the question is providing
that to you and they say sure right so
I'm just going to humor them and say
well let's just do the substitution I
think that's that's true okay there you
go done that's what they're after all
right now let's think about this because
if you remember that that flow chart
shows you a new 0 should always meet you
at the stationary point right except
know why was the most--it is outside the
debit fantastic okay now you should
always have your lights on thinking okay
they walked me through all this stuff
right they don't know that like they
don't commonly asked about domain it
comes out like maybe other way a quarter
of a third of the questions it's not
like Oh every single time they ask this
as opposed to pretty much every single
time they'll ask you for a drill bit if
if they can expect you to graph right
but this is a clue just like that about
right and we establish the domain we're
outside the doctor okay so the way i
would stake this is but our visitors say
x equals a objec this outside the domain
so it's live stationary point right now
what this is is just a specific case of
the fact that if we call back to this
simple example up here log functions
when you differentiate you get the
hyperbola and so the derivative exists
in more places than the original
function exists right because here is
the hyperbola there's the part that
matters but then you get this other part
for free right except you have to say
that's that's actually not the part I'm
interested in so when we differentiated
if we wanted to be really fancy
incorrect at this point i would say this
because this supplier's sure this it's
not always the derivative at some points
it's not outside the domains like
because is the function ok excellent so
there's Plan C Part D asks how it fits
inflection art how many points of
inflection others so how are we going to
a project yeah let's go to the sink do
dia right and it looks a bit messy but
remember I'm after when is the numerator
going to be 0 right and the numerator
will end up being fairly tidy ok it will
all sort of come out in the wash and I
don't have to worry about them to know
that is being the category ok so let's
differentiate again
okay I hope you've gotten a bit of the
way through question rule right now this
is where the cases where you can on
voice queres you just deal with it this
is what I ended up with and then I can
could I can't walk I'm looking for
points of inflection I have to include
this word made little worth big meeting
why is that yay all right now second
derivative because point of inflection
go where there is nicely changing some
company very good yes but like them the
second derivative may not exist was
changing therefore you may or may not X
so we're looking for changing can caddy
that's what a point of inflection is in
other words we have the secondary to be
negative somewhere and then possibly now
usually people positive the negative
usually if you change sign like that you
usually hit zero in the middle but we
have demonstrated you can hit zero in
the middle without having to change or
you can have the change without hitting
20 in the middle so it's like aa kind of
right this is the best shot we've got
there I'm going to get a solution out
right fear the dogged quadratic so you
have to do the project formula right and
you end up I believe you this
remembering tell Luke okay after your
crush them through now just pause for a
second right the question was how many
points of inflection are there right
what does this answer suggest to you it
suggests to it suggests to however the
answer is not to the answer is one why
is that
some of us have a look about the numbers
up now root 2 is about 1.4 about so what
does easy is minus 2 minus 1 point 4
that's like 30 no 3.4 it's okay um now
we've already demonstrated just like
with this guy right this guy down to
their me and that [ __ ] 3.4 is even
further I determine so therefore i would
say at this point but but x is going to
be greater than native one like i know i
know there's more stuff in here but is
specific to the domain but i don't need
all of that stuff that important part
for me is that i can't be to the left of
this i have to be to the right okay so
therefore one of these solutions that
negative case is it not okay so i would
say therefore x equals root 2 minus 2
only because i might as well put the
negative part time and it doesn't make
now i'm still not there yet right
remember we said this suggests there are
two points of inflection but actually
one of those poachers this suggests
there's one point of inflection but i
still don't know yet do i what do i need
i need to show the change in concavity
there's no way to avoid that except the
table values so it's not that
complicated um this value here if I
reform what do we say it's like about
1.4 so this is roughly negative point
six thank you [ __ ] now remember when
we talked about neighborhood before like
oh where do you go to the left and where
to go to the right you can clearly see
in this case you can't get very far at
all right because what would be an
obvious value to pick to the left an
obvious value would be negative one but
I can't do that right and an obvious lie
to the right would be 0 but I can't do
that either right so sometimes you have
to be a bit finicky the values that
items
were negative zero point seven this
value and negative 0.5 okay that's just
to the left just to the right I can't go
very much further than that so those are
the places where I'm going to test the
sensitivity now we're going to sit
through the rest of it because even
though there's more work you to be shown
to make sure you get to the very end
most of this stuff you're fairly
familiar and there are less like tricks
and shattuck the stuff with the domain
that I've already demonstrated I think
you'll be fine with it but just for the
sake of completeness let's fix it okay
let's finish this I've got a second
derivative of 7.0 or something blah blah
blah okay we already know what the
second movie there is and i've got
negative 4 over there okay should tada
my changing carry now I know it's a
point of inflection if you got different
values to me oh I'm motivated about that
but let me know I think they're okay
yeah so I've got my changing in
concavity so therefore i can make
included i can say since there is a
change in concavity that's what this
table Toby therefore is a point of
inflection X roof 2-2 all right so
there's this one is my point